welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the finale of Rick and
Morty season 6. episode 10 is now here
and throughout this video we're going to
be going through the latest entry scene
by scene this will cover all the Easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed as well as our review of the
episode and also the season and the
finale is called rational motoons Rick
Miss mulcation try saying that bastard
the episode is basically a Christmas
themed one and it's of course based on
National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation
throughout this video we're going to be
going through it all but please hit the
Thumbs Up Button one more time and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day now the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
Rick and Morty season 6 finale foreign
[Music]
Christmas lights which is what shows
typically tend to do for a Christmas
special this is a tradition from
throughout the ages and it was seen as
recently as the Guardians holiday
special with the Marvel Studios logo
being covered in them too at this point
Rick Bortles himself out of there and he
comes back as Rex Santa Chez calls his
name's of course Rick Sanchez so so I I
appreciate the little word play now he
comes bearing gifts from the Multiverse
and there's a couple of cool little
lines here that you might miss now for
Jerry he gives him the extended version
of Miracle on 34th Street the back of
the box says extended and we learned the
one from the alternate reality has two
extra hours of footage now it's not all
that the important thing is that Rick
gives Beth in space Beth the same
photograph of her and him when they were
younger from a universe where Beth
wasn't murdered as a child
wait what so Beth and Diane being
murdered by Rick Prime is basically what
changed the version of Rick that we
follow it was thought that Beth and
Diane being murdered was the exception
to the rule because every Rick has a
Morty and there has to be a bet for
there to be one however this line might
show their bets being murdered is just
as common and when you think about it
this will explain why there's so many
multiversal Ricks Rick turned down
portal travel and then ended up doing it
because of their deaths which might be a
rule that the other ones have followed
too either way I love how this is just
randomly thrown out there and not really
picked up on at all I'm guessing that
for every Universe in which Beth died
that there's one where she didn't and
this is how we also have countless
mortys this line also shows how they've
come to accept that their Rick isn't
really their Rick but they've made do
you don't know which Beth is the
original either so he's also got one for
space Beth he gets some money because
she's 17 and you might remember that in
the previously on segment from the story
Lord episode that we had her 18th
birthday which clearly clued him into it
not being a reality he also to get to
Mori a lightsaber and the handle looks
exactly like Luke Skywalker's one from
Return of the Jedi however the blade is
blue so it's not the same I'm kicking
off you got the blade color on you
[ __ ] this becomes really integral to
the plot and the gifts make it seem like
Rick's genuinely putting thought into
things that he's grown as a person
however we'll get into that more later
on and Morty goes to practice it within
the garage and Rick asks him to strike
him down this is of course what Ben and
the emperor both said in Star Wars and
it's a callback the franchise strike me
down what strike me down I'm not
striking you down strike me down Morty
I'll I'll become a pile of clothes like
that old guy
with me and your journey towards the
dark side will be complete at this point
Morty drops the lightsaber and it starts
to travel vertically through the floor
similarly acid blood from the Facehugger
and alien since nothing other than a
lightsaber can block a lightsaber it's
now on its way to the Earth's core they
travel through several basement bunkers
and we see one with people in red sacks
of liquid and the red liquid could also
be something that's shown up earlier in
the series during season 4 episode 2 we
saw the character Tony in something
exactly like this from the episode we
learned that it put the personal
simulation which made them live out
their version of Heaven the guy looks
stuff to be woken up and they travel to
a sushi spot located beneath the house
this Asian themed restaurant could be a
reference to a number of sci-fi movies
there was one in the fifth element and a
stop stop typing I'm gonna get the Blade
Runner as well don't know why I
mentioned Fifth Element first but yeah
it's in them both and it's sort of just
a sci-fi movie convention the chef here
also seems like he's super supposed to
be on Sushi Master Jiro he starred in a
movie called Giroud Dreams of Sushi
which if you're interested in sushi then
yeah go check that out tis the season
four clean balls
not really welcome to the sponsored part
of the video this video is sponsored by
madscaped manscaped is the perfect
One-Stop shop for all your holiday needs
and they've got the manscape performance
package 4.0 now on sale manscaped offer
a lot of things to help with your
stocking stuffer from the lawnmower 4.0
the weed whacker shampoos body washes
everything you need for your upstairs
and your downstairs they've got
deodorants gels exfoliants absolutely
everything you need to keep it clean
I've been using this stuff for over two
years now it's the first thing I go to
when I need to clean that chimney and
yeah I can't recommend manscape highly
enough don't let your chestnuts roast in
the wrong boxes check out the manscape
boxes I've even got them on now really
help with chafing if you want to go for
runs along walks you're not gonna feel
any friction and they're really gonna
help out now I've got a bit of a big
snozz uh some nasty ear has started
coming in as well I've just turned 34.
so the weed whacker has also been a
massive Lifesaver this year's 2.0 is
their full kit for Nail Care with
scissors Clippers tweezers and a file
for the traveling man there's also the
new preserved cologne which brings a
lovely Woodland smell to your tree trunk
area now if you're still using a loofah
as well they've also just introduced the
body buffer your old loofah will just be
holding onto dead skin and cells whereas
this new one would bring it in and it
acts tougher but it feels smoother and
last but not least is the lawnmower 4.0
use this all the time it's got skin safe
technology it's waterproof got a travel
lock feature as well so it doesn't set
off when you're on the go it's
absolutely perfect trimmer and it's
great for you or a gift for someone else
they've got a massive holiday sale on
right now with 20 off everything on the
entire side and also free shipping and
all you have to do to get it is go to
manscape.com heavy spoilers that's
manscape.com slash heavy spoilers for
that 20 off and also free shipping
manscape.com heavy spoilers for the
perfect gift that will be a holiday hit
thanks
at this point the curtain is pulled back
when Morty travels to level 10. we get a
reveal that the Rick we've been
following since roughly the midpoint of
the night of the sun entry is actually a
robot thought they were gonna say since
the first episode of the season but
that's not too bad it means all the
growth in this master entry still
happened however this therapy also
brought an epiphany with it rick
realized that in the same way that he
had several people who had him as a
nemesis that they all dealt with
deep-rooted psychological issues if he
doesn't tackle his then he'll deal with
the same thing and thus he's been trying
to track Prime Rick down however it also
extends beyond that he realized that
when Mori took the sword that he also
doesn't respect him anymore he let him
in and he stopped listening to him and
Rick fell betrayed by this now once the
lightsaber drops down we also also get a
call back in the previous entry it's
almost like someone designed me to be 22
more thoughtful than you that's it I'm
shutting you down don't you so I'm gonna
be like 22 more agreeable with you for
like maybe one episode or one Adventure
we'll see how it goes anyway Modi
doesn't want to ruin Christmas so he
won't expose what's being revealed and
we go back to the living room here we
see that it's a 1947 version of Miracle
on 34th Street and president Curtis
arrives to kick off about the lightsaber
we get a mention of kyber crystals which
are used within lightsabers and also a
breakdown of the big problems Star Wars
has you know what Curtis is right had
this discussion a lot recently when
shows like and or aren't getting watched
and I feel like things might have gone
too far however we fight on because
we're one with the force okay this plays
it off like he's above Star Wars and he
doesn't care but we learn that he's
actually after the lightsaber for his
own game anyway Morty takes Curtis into
the basement whilst Rick does some butt
matches can't really show any of these
because of the whole butt thing but this
is what primerick was doing in the tube
back in episode one it's some of the
only footage Rick has of him and thus
this is what he has to use back with
Morty we see crates being brought in and
this is through a portal doorway this is
something that the government have used
before and it popped up in season 3
episode 10 when we learned it was called
the nether portal now this is actually a
parody of the nether gate in Minecraft
and does also have lots of things that
it's similar to when people were placed
in a prison in the negative Zone during
Civil War we also had doorways like this
that allowed people to quickly put
prisoners through the lightsaber going
to the corner blow the entire planet up
is of course also a Star Wars reference
and though a lightsaber wasn't used
proton torpedoes going in the core of
the Death Star is what blew it up Rick
then arrives and says touch my [ __ ] and
die that's not a threat from me that's
how advanced my [ __ ] is this turns out
to be true as well as we see a
scientists like to die after touching
his stuff Rick's stuff is of course all
booby trapped and this too is mirrored
in Rick prime one of his machines
contains an explosive which just has
another explosive inside of it once it's
all taken apart there's so many good
lines here about how if you wanted the
government in his home how he just buy
an Alexa they've actually been used to
help solve murders due to them being
able to listen in zorzaker is saying he
looks like Phil Spector wiped his ass
with Randy Quaid
I know he maybe he does now Rick
volunteers to destroy the lightsaber but
they don't want his help at first
however eventually they ask him and I
love this little dig at Jerry I'm not
touching that thing I'll get
neurotypical cooties I have son-in-laws
more imaginative Rick sends in his own
lightsaber but it's sentient AI sends it
of course after it gets frustrated with
all the questions in Venice it starts a
meta spree and we seize the family
continue to watch the extended cutter
Miracle on 34th Street interestingly
this movie also ended up getting its own
holiday special in 1955 which is not not
that interesting to be honest now slowly
robot Rick's guilty conscious starts to
get the better of him and through
questions he answers that he's really a
robot Rick leaves Mori with a warning
that if he lets people in they'll betray
him and this is Meriden what happens
when they get the lightsaber both he and
the president flying to the core of the
planet like it's a second death star and
here they catch the blade the president
misses it up first but Morty grabs it
which reminded me a lot of the catch
scene at the start of Last Jedi even
though that was with the same character
now turns out that the president thinks
he now owns Star Wars and I kind of
think this is just a comment on fan
gatekeeping and how everyone thinks
they're the true fans even though
everyone knows I'm actually I'm actually
the true fan if the Ralph Macquarie hand
solo yeah if that isn't who you think is
the true Han Solo then you're not a true
fan you're not a [ __ ] fan and what he
returns home and the family still
haven't fully figured things out about
rickbot so Mori just announces that he's
a robot I love how Jerry just instantly
believes him and starts sewing into the
arm to reveal lots of wires we hear the
song The First Noel and over the top of
this we see the women of the family
attacking him typically Jerry hates
getting involved in the action and this
of course is also seen here as well bet
smashes a wine bottle which I thought
was hilarious and rickbach closes his
eyes accepting his fate turns out he's
actually a death seeker and huge shout
out to tvtropes.org for pointing out
that this is an archetypal character
that feels Dishonored and thus they seek
out to die by someone else's hand this
is shown throughout the episode at
several points like the door closing
later on and the character wants to
constantly be put out of his misery now
the ironic thing about rickbod is that
he actually has more Humanity than the
real one we'll talk about how he's
brought back later on but even I was sad
to see him go at this point now whilst
the Montage is going on we also see the
president practicing with his lightsaber
he puts a bowl on his head over his eyes
and this mimics the blast Shield that
Luke used to practice with in A New Hope
also popped up an attack of the Clones
and turns out that it was a real thing
that the Jedi used to do and not just
something Obi-Wan gave him because it
was lying around in the Millennium
Falcon it was really something there and
George Lucas understood what he was
doing now he drops it vertical and back
at the Smith Sanchez home we see as they
use rickbot to decorate the tree at this
point the president announces the
lightsaber problem and he blames Mori
for it and it's revealed he's in space
they bring wreckbot back online and this
is similar to how Ash was revived in the
first alien elsewhere in the basement we
also see that Rick has now Tracked Down
Rick Prime however upon doing this the
signals immediately start to duplicate
showing how he's always one step ahead
you see his Rick bot gets a lightsaber
and with Mori he travels out of the
White House in space this is sort of
like a death star in a way it will let
me explain before you kick off as it's
basically a base in space where the
final confrontation happens I kind of
feel like the gold body rickbod has
might also be another C3PO and the
president is very much a standing for
the emperor we see he has a secret room
with its own MOS Eisley Cantina a play
on hand being frozen in carbonite a TIE
fighter what's either a Thai Interceptor
Thai bomber or a tie Advanced there's
also an atsd a play on R2D2 and also the
window from the second death star shout
outs to our editor for saying that the
president's basically Richie from screen
five and he's the obsessed fan that
thinks he knows what's best
he sends in the battle droids which are
based on pitroids but the robot with a
lightsaber For Eyes ends up destroying
them all kind of feel like it's a
comment on General Grievous and he
brings them all down Morty goes defy the
lightsaber Gatling gun and this shows
that the president thinks what Star Wars
needs is just more lightsabers and
everything rickbot Dives in the way in a
get down Mr President moment and the
lightsabers slide down vertically which
is where we get a better look at the
Carbonite I'm not sure who this is meant
to be I thought it might be another
president but I can't really think of
who that looks like however if you know
you know where to drop it now this cuts
a hole in the floor and I love how
rickbott still denies he's a robot he
loses his hand and classic Star Wars
fashion and is saved by the real Rick
using portal Tech the death speech is so
good and it shows that if Rick built him
then he does really care the episode
ends with Rick inviting Modi to come
down and join him to find Rick Prime the
season then closes out with a tirade of
Rick going off explaining what C season
7's gonna be and this is very similar to
the Rick and Morty for 100 years thing
that he did in episode one he says them
hunting him won't be every episode but
it'll be laced through some of them and
we might not even know if they're doing
it in the background only they'll know
about it though and from here we jump to
the post credit scene now in typical
season finale fashion We join Mr Poopy
butthole whereas the last one had him at
home explaining how he'd lost it all we
see him here in the gym working out love
the little detail on the episode
description as well and if we pause it
we can see this is an episode watch it
just watch me do it again you already
did it fill the holes of your
meaningless existence with more of this
same content which is nice now he drinks
a raw egg similar to Rocky and breaks
his legs trying to squat too much guy
still wants to reach out to Amy who who
hasn't blocked and we also get a mention
of Roy from the life well lived game and
that ends the series which yeah I
enjoyed it rank you know what it ranks
up there is one of my favorite ones yes
I'm Shilling so yeah had a blast with
the season and I hope you had a good
time too thank you for rocking with me
every week what do you mean you skipped
episode 5 breakdown you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] kill ya
anyway that's a video and let me know
your thoughts Below on the episode in
the season we are in a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
House of the Dragon season one on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out another breakdown linked on screen
now we've got the boys spin-off trailer
gen V it's a good one so yeah go head
over there right after this jelly
Transformers you might have that as well
on the channel go check it out and I'll
see you on the next one you take care
yourself peace